Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to animal inspector I found
This game on its Itch.io because it looked
adorable but it seemed to have rather
Sinister implications such as this
newspaper article! Too many animals
Government declares animal crisis...
Can I read the comics- oh shit, gun fancy. the
last buck meets its hunter
Oh jeez hunting in a world without wild
animals?
Oh jeez oh secret murder agency?
Please don't kill me? oh god the
president wants your pets!
They came for my cat! Oh, snout and soul
First impressions. Oh wow!
The cat that dodged inspection. Okay?
Oh hi, woah holy shit. How are you? Hi pup!
Hello doggo! My perfect boy, how you doing?
What do I- what am I supposed- my truest
friend
I agree, doggos goes are the best.
Noble and fierce. yeah, you'll be
inspected soon.
Oh god, that doesn't sound good. but I
won't wait for that. They're hiring agents
I've already applied. you're a good dog
I won't let them take you... Good!
Okay, great I'm going to save the animals!
I'm going to save all the doggos, yeah, yeah!
I'm animal inspector 0315 , bring it on!
Oh hello there. My name is Martha. it is
wonderful to meet you dear
Are you just starting out here as well?
Yeah! Drag a fish toy into my mo-outh...
Oh my god, the text thing is a giant cat!
oh god oh how
exciting.
Well I'm very much looking forward to
this. it will be good for me to get out
of the house.
I just do not get out as much as I should.
do you see that young man over there?
no. oh now I do, hello.
I tried talking to him earlier. his name
is Alan.
He was a little rude, so I'm glad that
you're here.
Oh but enough of this, i'm very excited
to work with you.
well to work near you in any case. heheh.
okay. oh hey. you all are the new
employees?
okay, well I'm in charge here, um, listen
up.
this job is pretty straightforward. every
day you'll get a stack of forms, go
through each one and stamp them. approve
good or useful animals, reject bad or
useless animals. don't skip any. oh god,
it's like a papers please style
animal inspection. we take this job very
seriously.
um yeah one more thing. please make sure
to comment on every animal you process
process. explain your reasoning.
oh jeez its a legal thing. yeah I don't
know, that's it I guess.
ok, cool, oh god I don't like
feeding the chat box.
ok, that's it? isn't there any training? a
rule book or something?
Um no use your best judgment. I'll let
you know if you screwed up. but try not
to screw up.
You'll Fuck your mum tommorow
I'm starting off easy but please be
thorough. well I don't know- he seems nice
you think so too, right? no, hmm.
Oh dear, well it seems that our day is
about to begin.
it's time to go inspect some animals.
ehhh do you try to be a little more
enthusiastic deer.
these animals need you after all. oh
i dont know. aww looks like such a good, aww he's a goof
aww he's such a goof. we all love this fuzzy
dog a lot.
Oh "adorable doggo a++ would doggo
again"
check box. BOINK. yeah did I screw up? does this mean
next?
ok. let's see, nature: aloof, kills mice
"she didn't let me touch her until a few
months ago, but now I pet her every day"
all right. "good hunter hunter cattums" BOINK
yeah, I'm doing great. house cat, timid, reminder of simpler days. easily becomes
afraid but this cat is good. he is family.
"family means Ohana,
ohana is fam fam" BOINK  ah shit
there we go. yeah! i got a thumbs up
am I good? all right! please tell me I'm
good.
okay, um, welcome back i guess. pretty good
job yesterday.
pretty good. some of you, and I won't name
any names but you know who you are,
Have been a little too liberal with approvals. the
whole point of this agency is to cull the
heard. That means you can't just blindly let everything through.
from now I'll need you to reject at least
one animal? failure to do so will result
in a strike?! ohhh nooo
well umm, i didn't really think I need to
explain this, but when you comment on
forums you should um, just trying to
spell things correctly.
nah! i mean I know mistakes happen,
but your job is kind of not to make mistakes,
and you made some with that last batch
maybe you don't think spelling is
important, but you're a professional now,
so please try to act like it. just a warning this time.
but if this happens again I'll
have to give you a strike.
ah god damn it! ok so it's just a warning, but
please clean up your forms a little bit
before turning them in.
there should be a little feather duster on
your desk, standard issue
so use it maybe. no.
ok, um, seriously, wow, *laugh laugh* i'm just gonna
pretend like i didn't hear that.
anyway. oh no god!
come on! hello again. how was your first
day?
bad? I'm sorry to hear that, dear. my day
was grand
such wonderful and cute animals i had.
course I proved them all. though I guess
I cannot do that anymore.
good luck today dear. hey.
we never really talked earlier. i'm alan.
i don't think i'll be here very long.
this is bottom of the barrel stuff. sincerely
bad. like really just the worst.
you know what I'm saying yeah? yep,
actually I do Alan, heh.
yeah you get me. anyway, it's good to meet
ya. bye alan- oh its a sneeak!
oh this is my snake, it's very neat, but
my friends are scared of it, but I'm not.
Oh clean it up. clean it clean it.
ok it did it. all right. l'ts see.
housecat, nervous, shed civilian appeal:
none
well that dopey ass cat might be going
soon.
ancient hound resigned good for petting.
Mike's the family dog. he's old but part
of the household.
oh no. oooh nooo! someone out there watching is gonna hate me
for what I pick
oh it's an old dog oh but I cant it looks
just like Lucy could get wonderful dog
i love you lucy
oh god
Oh quiet snake snakes eat mice
no need for elimination
no need for culling because this is a
good bird
oh god I'm sorry
sorry I'm so sorry oh god that's all I'm gonna say
did i do good did i do good
don't give me a strike well ah it's a
new day so umm theres been a space
concern basically what i mean by that is
there are some concerns about space
specifically the space all these animals
are taken up
I guess what I'm trying to say is we've
prioritized projection of larger animals
all things being equal anyways anything
close human size since im talking about
alot of people sized animals
unbelievable after all the whole point
of this is to make space i guess
scoop you
hello dear sorry but I'm a little down
today
here that Alan has been rejecting all of
his animals I just do not agree with
that but he does not want to listen to
me called me after you said that I'm out
of touch
can you believe that
No No thank you dear
you're so much nicer than Alan also i'm
not proud of it but I rejected an animal
not a cat of course
it was a fish the natural enemy of
cats
oh yeah okay but still did not feel good
not at all dear i know we have our
instructions but I do not think you
should be rejecting cats
I just do not think it is right that's a
very intelligent creatures you know
Oh in some ways a cat is smarter than you
realize
ok I was on your side for a little bit
there you need to back off with you
it's maybe a lot of ways smart okay well
then Martha what you take your bitches
mish and take it and go have fun with
your cats that I reject
so do you understand now you promised to
approve the cats
no oh I guess that was a hard promise to
make me think maybe you could have tried
oh yeah so see you late ok bye how's it going
I've been getting rid of pretty much all
my animals seriously I've got no
tolerance for useless things
I mean I love this job but I'm gonna do it
well see you around
all right fuck you Alan oh look at him
oh and we can get rid of ants but
they're tiny
oh geez Oh feisty little pump
oh no no the dogs big
Oh No fuck ants
ants have no use well they have some
use but i'm just going to say that
through feisty feisty dog is good dog
approve lets see big because he has lots of
love to give
i wish i could misspell gosh dang it
doink doink and boink ok so
good morning
I just got word from the department head
basically well they think you've all
been doing great really great so great
in fact that they're bumping up the
inspection quota
so now you have five animals each look
through all so this means you need to
reject 2 because there are more all go
by the way i'm starting to question your
judgment that dog did an inspection
agent and we didn't terminate it right
there was just a formality shouldn't
have to double check your work
honestly that's kind of my entire job I
can tell that you're going to be a
problem employee fuck you man
strike three on this but come on look a
little smarter
this job is not what I thought
it would be
I'll try my best to be fair to these
animals but it's not very easy
the boss is giving us lots of
instructions instructions i do not
always agree with
oh man this job and I want to say this
too loudly but well it's boring yeah
real drag
repetitive god can you imagine doing
this for the rest of your life
appreciation for education be a part of
the is basically at the end of her life
oh god shes old
oh hi Marthas I'm looking at you
ok yice and yet this is where everything
led her
man you're really happy it's not me like
i said i don't think i'll be here long
oh alright i guess you might be here
awhile - okay i mean this is what makes
you happy then cool
well it's not oh you're kidding
look at the little squeaky be key
oh that is shouting just give it back
give it the sound of a rooster clap
oh that's good this one this out of her
sister to care about both of the same
time
oh geez I gotta pick between cats worth
is not gonna like this one
they're so cute
no they're twins I can't get rid of the
twins
I mean I can't get rid of one twin I'd
have to get rid of both twins
good we're gonna pick Morgan a pig twins
the twins God together
good twins me to be together
no sage is a good name
affectionate is good boy
finding stuff is cool huh
I'm emotionally devastated at the most
good
ok so I'm sorry to say but
Oh Mindy has come down with the case of
the flu you know Mindy
Oh Mindy Martha everyone knows Mindy
in any case well someone needs to take
her place in the cages today that
someone is Alan
okay yeah okay well cool
I'm up for anything Alan's been chosen
because of his exemplary exemplary XX
limp blurry exemplary there you go
performance here these past few weeks
right on you all have been doing well no
need to worry about increased quotas
good work out there everybody oh oh dear
what do you think about that crazy
well I'm sure glad that I'm not going
the cases are no place for me here
I've heard some bad things about that
place is scary things
things are not good at all dear by the
way here I just want to tell you that I
understand I understand that you had to
reject those cats not sure that I would
have been able to do the same
I still do not agree but I know this job
is important to you
I'm glad that it was not a linear
inspected the cats I just hope that i do
not have to make that choice
oh man i'm not exactly sure what to
expect but anything's better than doing
paperwork all day
honestly I'm pumped about it very
excited thrilled is the beginning of a
good thing for me I can feel it
ok
oh look at all it kills birds
it's basically doing my job for us dog
useless dog just takes up space
oh I see oh wait a minute
whoa hang on a second wait what wait
what
man arrogant 2626 this is me
it's a Talon is on solid bad face
I don't know I don't know what that
means 62 years old
all right
rolled golden fish is dead
if it's dead it's let's see
I appreciate a good squad
all dogs are useful ok let's see what
happens when I reject the person i
wonder if this is actually gonna do
something for me
wait a minute oh ok well i think i speak
for all of us when I say documentaries
are great documentaries are important
government tools and show the public
that we're just like that
my favorite documentary is
well I forgot the title but it's about a
wolf raised by a nice
the wolf grows up and eats the geese the
message we all can learn from
in any case there's a reason I'm
bringing this up
believe it or not they're making a
documentary about this department
so in order to present us all in the
best possible light I'm asking you
well telling you actually I'm telling
you to approve all your animals today
understood No
okay well if you want to get fired that
badly then there's not much I can do to
stop you
arm on an unannounced announcement
before he started seems that Alan is no
longer
Oh everything is fine but war
well there was an issue with the cages
whoa just a slight mix-up overall it's a
nothing too much to worry about
oh that was Alan rejected
Alan he was a good employee a good boy
will be missed for or no hope
oh dear what could have happened al and
I did not like him much but it's very
concerning your i told you i had heard
bad things about that place of the boss
does not good for their little walking
down here this documentary will be very
exciting anything
it means we do not have rejected the
animals will tell you though I'm getting
a little worried about my cats have not
come up for inspection yet very anxious
it's want them to be okay oh look at the
dog okay Kat are you doing
fish do I care everything here is a
feeder
I'll just go ahead and reject the oh no
I need to improve everything okay
everything
00 foothill ok
alrighty then dog oh my dog goes
Oh adorable daughters everything gets
love love it
great bird good
it's the awesome dog swell up good smile
all right grandma Santa
well d day has come and gone that's dr.
by the way documentary day because they
were filming a documentary activity yes
ok again he's mad news the good news is
that the filming went well they got all
the shots he needed they're done with
his office
the bad news is that we are now
extremely behind on returning water so
I'm gonna need you to already checked
everything today
no exemptions I thought things were
getting better around here yesterday was
so nice today will be awful
not sure what you do it every all over
animals will be bad thick as possible
right dear
no oh foot pursuit
no oh no I know what's gonna happen her
cats are gonna come up
Oh No in fights kind this is my baby
its water zone I have to I have to save
it
I have to save it oh my god of killing
the dog goes in favour can do it I can
do so sorry so sorry
parked in a rock
he and my mother had a saying
hang in there I don't think she made it
up which is your set it a lot because
I'm trying to say is I know things are
rough
remember to hang in there being said
maybe a sick again
little Mindy it's really been sick a lot
recently is gracious
wow it took over last time enough
well he's not with us anymore so it's
your turn will take over from india
today
set down to the cages fall you down into
bed with instructions
ok you didn't you understand
really so hard to just reject everything
there's nothing to think about
oh god no no I'm gonna die
sorry let's step back a bit
I guess I do understand horses cat well
this car because it's good to stick
together
I really do have two addresses so we
missed our quota yesterday
the records are clear and someone has to
take the fall I still need to give a
strike is only for your first strike so
don't worry too much
but if you get three you're done also
okay well we should talk
I know I never mentioned this before but
I'm well you are really need to bury
your comments like don't just write the
same thing and i'll come on Randall you
cover creature is special and they all
deserve to die or get it I guess
well anyways which case it really
oh my goodness dear my cat my lovely
kidding you saved her
here you'll never know how much this
means to me you must have gotten a
strike for this
I'm so sorry about that i do not think
you like me and so happy to be wrong
again thank you so much on please be
careful dear
I still think about what happened to Al
and the boss will not talk about it with
me
something bad is going on I can feel it
Oh No welcome to the cages
look so much different down here you're
probably wondering where all the actual
cages are well rest assured there are
definitely some cages in here
they're behind a few more doors you'll
see them soon but first i'm sure you
have a few questions
maybe you wanted to ask what this place
is yeah let's go with that is not throw
well i'll tell you you've been part of a
little experiment
well I guess it's more of a big
experiment
but anyways I have a few questions for
you and I'll explain everything
please try to answer as honestly as
possible wow what
first question have you noticed anything
odd during your time here
yes hmm interesting oh you don't want me
to expand on that
oh ok. Is goal of this organization clear
for you. no
ok let me just mark that down there
question would you describe everyone
here is normal no
ah would you describe Martha as abnormal
know what about me
weird rude well fuck you too right
I did ask though well I think we're just
about done here
thanks very much for your time so i
guess you noticed there's something
funny going on
well I'll explain a few things so first
of all
Alan rest in peace Alan wasn't a real
person
what i mean by that is an Allen wasn't
always the way he was the allen you were
interacting with was actually an animal
what's a dog specifically meet right
kinda faster
hell yeah it is anyways look we've been
researching how to train animals to do
an immediate labor like your job
stamping forms we can train animals to
do it
of course to do that we have to set them
up with nicer brains and we see those
brains with human memories
so they can actually function in Alan's
case we gave mountains memories
Alan the dogs case we gave the dog
Alan the memories of human Alan not that
the dog Allen's name was originally
allen - I mean that would be weird
coincidence
anyways when you have someone's memories
you kind of freaked out if you don't
actually look like them so then we make
that happen
look I won't get into the specifics like
technology is pretty advanced these days
so we can basically make an animal
passes human and we don't have to pay
them
so all these pets we've been rejecting
their an untapped workforce and we're
tapping them course you didn't notice
that something was off
so we still have some work to do
human-sized the animals they wanted
rejected all but yeah that makes sense
No okay well I mean look I don't mean to
imply this idea is bulletproof
you have to admit it's pretty solid . .
. okay hold up
what's your problem name one issue with
this plan just one car fixed
huh I guess it is a little absurd how
much money we've put into this but we
probably won't ever really make it back
the money isn't everything it some of
mankind's greatest dreams were
profitable
so that's all you got to claim about
morals
well yes we were experimenting with
people's pets
what kind of wiped out the wilderness a
little that's not great
and I mean if we're giving an animal
someone's memories it's really so
different than us at that point
and what would happen if someone met
their animal clone
it's kind of spooky to be honest with
that surprised me paying for progress
the greater good it will all be worth it
in the end really
of course I mean probably maybe
well I guess there's not any obvious
benefit over in too deep at this point
we just got to keep pushing through
you have to agree with that right not
really
look I know there are some issues here
like it's kind of weird that we're using
animals for this robots would probably
have been made more sense strategy of
technology and I mean what's the end
goal here
what's all the jobs are done by animals
then what what if the animals think
they're human than we probably will have
to pay them
ok so this whole plan is a little weird
there's a tiny bit but I think we've
covered all the flaws at this point I
mean every plan has its downsides there
aren't any absolutes in this world
this plan may not be perfect but really
what is so you see now right
you're on board with our strategy no
listen I'm getting real sick of your
attitude here
I was trying to be nice about this try
to answer all your questions but I can
see that you aren't going to be
cooperative
I don't think i can really let you leave
at this point you're a troublemaker a
real piece of work
so is your home now well you'll be
pleased to know that your replacement
will be your very own dog
so it's not all bad it anyway
welcome to the rest of your life
wow wow oh god no oh geez
wow what a game
what an adventure oh geez
oh it's all my approvals it's all my
cards
family meeting til 10 but it's for him
for a horrible dog oh good hand to York
Adams
oh no book jeez oh jeez it's all my sins
it's all my sins laid bare oh man that
was awesome that was awesome
I really like that I like that a lot
that was an awesome game
I can't describe it any more than
awesome try not to use the c-word
you know the word i'm talking about not
that C word with the other C word but
you know it's a great game
I liked a lot so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play
this i'll put a link to it in the
description below
apparently there's probably a lot of
different ways to go about this game and
maybe a different ending to explore may
be multiple different endings I have no
idea but anyway you'll find that out for
yourself let me know your thoughts in
the comments below I really wanted to
hear your opinions on it so thank you
everybody so much for watching
as always I will see you in the next
video
Buh~Bye!!